Virginia's embattled Democratic governor
and lieutenant governor are still
refusing to leave office in the midst of
their twin scandals correspondent
Garrett teni has our update tonight from
Richmond the Expo forgiveness and I
believe that we need to give the
governor a second chance Virginia
governor Ralph Northam receiving some
encouragement from a group of
african-american clergy and local
leaders who say Northam different man
today than thirty years ago when he wore
blackface in an interview with CBS the
governor said he's not going anywhere
and wants to use this controversy to
help him address racial inequality in
his state right now Virginia needs
someone that can heal there's no better
person to do that then a doctor I will
focus on race and equity that's
something that for the next three years
is going to be my commitment to Virginia
and I really think we can make impactful
changes but Northam also drew fresh
criticism from the interview for the way
he described the first Africans brought
to Virginia by slave traders 400 years
ago just 90 miles from here in 1619 the
first indentured servants from Africa
landed on our shores and Old Point
Comfort what we call now Fort Monroe and
wild also known as slavery yeah
lieutenant governor Justin Fairfax is
also refusing to step down after being
accused by two women of sexual assaults
I do want to reiterate that Justin
Fairfax should resign this morning
delegate Patrick Hope announced he's
holding off on impeachment proceedings
to remove Fairfax from office while
lawmakers explore other options for
investigating the claims against him
both affair faxes accusers say they are
willing to testify at impeachment
hearings but at the Capitol not everyone
is convinced the General Assembly would
be able to conduct a meaningful
investigation the General Assembly does
not have the ability to subpoena
witnesses we need to make sure that they
are able to present their individual
cases before a body that's actually
going to be able to do something with it
the Fox News has learned that four
staffers of Lieutenant Governor Justin
Fairfax have resigned since Friday when
a second woman came forward with sexual
assault allegations Fairfax has also
been placed on leave by the
law firm where he works until an outside
investigation into the allegations is
complete
Brett Garrett any live in Richmond
Garrett thanks